hello everyone i'm john mcenroe today
i'll be answering your questions from
twitter this is tennis support
[Music]
first up tim
wtf why do tennis players have such an
explosive temper always here see them
having a meltdown on the court you must
be watching
different tournament than me because i
don't see many players having meltdowns
at all and i know something about
meltdowns my past experience and i see a
couple players obviously nick herios
comes to mind having meltdowns on a
pretty regular basis but for the most
part tennis players are incredibly well
behaved maybe too well behaved in my
book i'd like to see a little bit more
explosive temper see the emotions you
know wearing on their sleeve there's a
handful of people you see that but i
just saw someone win wimbledon on the
girl's side who didn't show any emotion
so i don't know if any of us want to see
that so perhaps there's a happy medium
jimmy asked me can someone explain to me
what a bagel is in tennis well bagels in
new york taste great uh love bagels our
version of a bagel would be not allowing
the opponent to win a single game in a
set skash
27 i think i got that right why do
tennis players get three tennis balls
before every serve look at them for a
few seconds and then toss them back
aren't they all identical weird stuff as
he said they're probably pretty similar
and it probably is sort of overrated
balls pick up some felt and they pick up
clay if they're on clay courts and they
get beat up on a cement court as you can
imagine and even on grass these players
men and women are hitting it so hard now
it's different than when you pull it out
of a can and so you place seven nine
games the ball is going to be a little
heavier a little bit deader so that's
why players are always looking to sort
of get the freshest ball possible so
that when they're serving
that's the people that are looking at it
they want to get the two freshest balls
so they can hit it a little bit harder
to me what i try to do try to get a
fresh ball and sort of be able to use
that to my advantage of course if the
returner hits it well then
that could probably negate
the advantage i think at the end of the
day you see certain players now i see
djokovic for example he doesn't care
what ball he has and he seems to be
doing pretty well and here we got
michael who is your toughest opponent
you face in your tennis group i had
the opportunity fortunately to play a
lot of great players won and lost did my
share of losing against a lot of them
hopefully winning some bjorn borg
obviously was my greatest rival jimmy
connors was an incredible competitor
along the likes of rafael nadal that
effort he gave was very intimidating
ivan lendo was a bigger stronger guy
when he was on it was extremely
difficult but i think we brought out
mostly the best in each other my
toughest opponent i ever played though
at the end of my career unfortunately
and the beginning of his his name was
pete sampras and it felt like i just
had the racket taken out of my hands
like it didn't matter what i did almost
he served so big and was hitting the
ball so hard that i i wasn't able to do
my thing he took me out of my game and i
wasn't moving as well as i was earlier
in my career so that made it a lot worse
laura
hawk ridge why is servant volley become
virtually extinct in tennis it has
historically been one of the most
effective and entertaining styles of
play true as a matter of fact that was
my game served volley the courts used to
be in poorer condition when i played way
back when and three of the four majors
were played on grass a lot of bad
bounces soft bounces so therefore it was
encouraged when i grew up and the other
players in the 60s 70s into the 80s grew
up serving volley because you take the
ball in the air so you didn't have to
worry about a bad bounce 20 years ago
they made a decision to change the grass
or they changed it to some type of rye
grass i don't know why that's thicker i
don't know why the bounce is truer i
sort of wish i had it when i played so
you didn't have to worry about it but
what it's done is completely altered the
style because people can bank on a truer
bounce and therefore not have to change
their game as much and play more from
the baseline so that's why you're seeing
baseline players succeeding at wimbledon
whereas before that was almost never
happened so it's definitely been a huge
change i think in a way it's for the
better because you just don't want to
serve serve and thank you very much
which you were seeing more and more with
the likes of pete sampras and gordon
ivanizovich now you're seeing this great
all-court play and these legendary
champions doing the diverse things on
the court which is amazing ian asked me
why do you have to break your tennis
racket if you don't like it anymore give
it to a fan in the stands how about we
compromise we break a tennis racket and
then you give it to fan in the sands a
broken racket it's a win-win there's a
person in the stands going to use it i
would hope that if you got a racket from
nick kyrios in
a moment of his frustration that you'd
maybe hang it up put it up somewhere
frame it
not use it i doubt you'd be using you
know oh i've i'm hitting with you know
novak djokovic's racket which he broke
in a fit of anger no i don't i think
you'd have it like a piece of art or
something you know be happy that maybe
you have a racket at all if you get it
so we can both be winners get out the
frustration and you get the racket karen
d
why do doubles players congratulate each
other
even if they lose the point i couldn't
agree with you more okay it is total bs
total bs when they lose a point hey you
know great work uh i think it should be
a rule that you're not allowed to
high-five an opponent unless you win the
point
so i'm totally with you there i hated
doing it when i played i see it happen
all the time it's you know keep their
spirits up keep positive but it's gotten
totally out of control it's like you
just hit the ball in the bottom of the
net we don't need to high-five each
other mommy girl a cpa how do i pick a
tennis racket out i'm having a mental
breakdown in dick's sporting goods i
haven't been there recently i don't know
the prices of rackets i've been
fortunate enough to be able to get free
rackets for a long time did they let you
test rackets out would be my question do
you allowed to go in and grab one and
say i'll be back in a couple days let me
feel it out but they all work just go
out there and have some fun
apparently it's not me who invented
tennis it's so weird who invented a
tennis i my first question would be why
do you think it's so weird it's pretty
great game actually but i heard it was
some king or
queen or something maybe going out in
the grass court put a net over it and
hit a ball i don't know but it uh i
think it's a pretty awesome game all in
all it's a tough game but when you do it
right it feels pretty damn good how many
rackets do tennis players take on court
i used to take six you know when i
thought i was a hot shot i think guys
take up six to eight rackets now even
the girls and sometimes they get them
restrung during the match so there's a
lot of stuff going on two-hand or
one-handed backhand it's a good question
i i would go two-hand now if i was a kid
you're little you're not strong enough
i'm a one-hander i loved it but that
shot up high is tough balls are coming
up higher and higher players are taller
so uh i would go with that one but i'd
work on the volley too and being able to
hit a one-hander at double fault king
someone's making this up right this
anyone knows how to improve mental
strength during a tennis match during
the tennis match wow it's difficult to
answer that one so i would suggest the
best way to have mental strength during
a tennis match is to sort of understand
your opponent and what he's good at it
or he or she is good at and not good at
and you could take it from there sort of
be aware of what you do well and what
the other person maybe doesn't do well i
always tell my kids at my tennis academy
to try to make things as easy for
yourself and as difficult as possible
for your opponent jake
has asked me what's my favorite shot in
tennis i would say the return of serve
because these guys serve so big i love
to see what a guy like djokovic can do
how difficult it is so that would be my
call there the usta in georgia many
coaches
teach in many different ways true what
has been the best advice you have
received for tennis hmm best advice that
would be tough to come up with the one
thing you have a mantra at my tennis
academy don't beat yourself i think
that's a hell of a start this one's a
little harsher it doesn't matter whether
you win or lose
until you lose maybe that would give
some people impetus to try a little
harder you want the joy of winning to be
something that you really
experience and like
not like it's a relief i won i don't
have to feel so bad that i lost so
there's an old saying from an
ex-american president this from like a
hundred years ago it's something that i
try to go by as well it's better to try
and fail than not try at all we all have
this fear of failure and so it's how do
we deal with it how do you vent that how
do you handle how to use it to your
advantage how do you not let it
overwhelm you so those are the questions
from tennis support hope you enjoyed it
i'm john mcenroe hope to see you again
in the future